It wasn't that long ago that Keanu Reeves
made his first appearance as headshot-happy,
dog-loving hitman John Wick in the critically
acclaimed film of the same name.
In the years since, though the world of assassins
and gold coins that he lives in has grown
considerably, and will be expanding a whole
lot more in the near future.
There's already a line of comic books slowly
revealing more about Wick's shadowy past,
and a TV spinoff is currently in the pipeline
at Starz.
Both are exciting projects, but it's Reeves'
third outing as the steely anti-hero that
everyone's really waiting for.
From returning characters and exotic filming
locations to production schedules and release
dates, this is everything we know about John
Wick: Chapter 3.
The band’s back together
The biggest obstacle for John Wick: Chapter
3 was always going to be convincing Keanu
Reeves to reprise his role.
As he found out with the Matrix trilogy, third
time isn't always a charm.
Luckily for Wick fans, Reeves was expressing
his interest in a third film before the second
one was even released.
In February 2018, Reeves said that he was
"absolutely" on board for John Wick: Chapter
3, telling Entertainment Weekly that he loves
the character and the world, and that if audiences
were into what he did in the sequel, he’d
have the chance to continue.
It turns out they did.
Chapter 2 racked up an 89% Fresh rating on
Rotten Tomatoes, and Reeves got his wish,
with Chapter 3 being set for release in summer
2019.
Writer Derek Kolstad came aboard in summer
2017, and Chad Stahelski, who co-directed
and directed John Wick and Chapter 2, respectively,
is back on board, too.
Familiar faces
With John Wick’s success, it’s no surprise
that producers have been spending a whole
lot of time figuring out how to continue the
character’s story.
When Chad Stahelski was asked for more details,
he revealed that Chapter 3 is going to bring
a few characters from the periphery of the
action into the spotlight.
Stahelski has mentioned that Ian McShane and
Lance Reddick will both be back in prominent
roles, meaning that the Continental, a hotel
that caters to working assassins, will likely
play a key role in the film.
Wick was excommunicated from the hotel for
conducting business on its grounds in Chapter
2, but judging from these early comments,
it looks like he’s not done with the secretive
underworld establishment just yet.
Common, Laurence Fishburne, and Ruby Rose
are all preparing to reprise their roles as
well.
The last time we saw Rose's character, the
mute assassin Ares, she was bleeding out in
a hall of mirrors after making the mistake
of fighting John Wick.
Apparently it’ll take more than that to
stop her.
On the road
While John Wick was set entirely in New York,
Chapter 2 took him to the gloriously cinematic
city of Rome, and it looks as though he'll
be getting at least one new stamp in his passport
in part three.
According to Stahelski's interview with Digital
Spy, the plan is to keep Wick on the move,
and numerous destinations have already been
tossed around behind closed doors.
Stahelski said,
"We talked about the UK, Paris, we'd love
to do the Middle East and Asia."
Reeves even told IGN that he’d like to see
John in Jerusalem, sending him into the desert
in an effort to go somewhere with a history
that goes beyond even Rome’s.
It ultimately falls to writer Derek Kolstad
to shape Wick's journey, and his choice is
Tokyo, who told the Jeff Goldsmith Podcast,
"One of the things I would love John to do
in the third one is to be excommunicated,
broke, begging, in Tokyo or some corner of
the Earth that’s sexy and cool."
Taking the story to Japan might help to underline
Wick’s status as a sort of modern-day ronin,
and recent reports suggest that this might
just be what the producers are going for.
Hiroyuki Sanada, who formed a friendship with
Reeves on the set of the samurai flop 47 Ronin,
has apparently joined the cast as the central
antagonist: the boss of a Japanese crime syndicate.
Pull up a chair to the High Table
While 2014's John Wick was a straight-up revenge
flick, the 2017 sequel fleshed out the mysterious
world of professional killers considerably,
revealing the existence of an all-powerful
council of assassins and crime lords known
as "The High Table."
“The Camorras doubled Santino's open contract,
it's gone international."
“High table?”
According to Kolstad,
"In one of the early script drafts we went
in-depth on what the High Table is until we
realized it was too much for one story."
Luckily, Kolstad's interview seemed to indicate
that Chapter 3 will finally go for it, which
was then confirmed by the director.
Reeves also teased the High Table's involvement
in Chapter 3 during an interview with Empire,
saying,
"Maybe the High Table shows up.
And then the High Table starts firing guns.
And then maybe this kind of thing starts to
happen between the High Table and Continental?"
Wouldn’t that be awesome?
John Wick: The End
As it stands, John Wick: Chapter 3 will be
the last movie that will focus on Reeves'
character, at least as far as the filmmakers
are concerned.
Asked by The Independent if he saw the third
chapter as the final one, Chad Stahelski's
answer was yes, although he left the final
decision in the hands of Lionsgate.
It seems like there’s a slim chance Reeves
could return in a fourth film, but it’s
more likely that the studio is planning on
doing more John Wick movies without the character.
According to the Hollywood Reporter, Lionsgate
has already purchased a screenplay called
Ballerina, described as Luc Besson meets Quentin
Tarantino, with the intention of releasing
it as a John Wick spinoff.
There's been little news of the project since,
which suggests that Lionsgate intend to see
the John Wick trilogy out before expanding
the universe.
That doesn't mean that Keanu Reeves will never
play the character again, though.
In January 2018, Starz, the television network
owned by Lionsgate, confirmed that it was
developing a TV series called The Continental.
While it’s based on the hotel that Wick
and the other assassins frequent, it’s been
revealed that Reeves would not be the star,
but will still reprise the role for occasional
appearances.
With Chapter 2 introducing an incredible number
of new characters and Chapter 3 set to possibly
involve a conflict between the Continental
and the High Table, there’s plenty to work
with in the wider John Wick universe… as
long as all the assassins know they should
stay away from everyone’s pets.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!